hello freak but that's what VD
is you know V DS of sexual transmitted
disease when we talk about someone
having VD when I was about 17 my friend
his sister's best friend and he's
got something he got VD he got VD and we
went to the next day and there was a
chick with like like the Phantom
of the Opera mark on her face dog it was
crazy
what was the mark on her face like she
she had like syphilis at home and
started he like she had a cut in her lip
and she sucked the up Dickerson
and it ran I'll never forget this I it's
not even funny it was really sad because
I didn't know what she had I just went
there with my friend my friend goes you
got to go in there with me doc I'm
scared to walk in there let's go what's
the big deal they give you pills
whatever I didn't know I was a sexually
active at that age like he was and we
were in there always wait for him though
this chick came and did paperwork and
she turned around and she had gotten
something that started here like you
know she had like a cod or what's that
when you have chapped lips or something
and all this was like half purple and
red she sucks something bad and after
that I was like who I gotta be careful
out there it's a jungle that was the
thing we were kids like someone has VD
she's got VD be careful he's got VD you
know someone having VD was like whoa
you're here do you hear Betty got BD
whoa that girl got VD he's
friends with me from high school and a
wouldn't get wet I used to call
the dry hump family in New Jersey needs
to call a fabulous girl was bangin
this girl was banging though so
you'd have to like bring Vaseline or
something yeah she was from Wayne New
Jersey
and she was banging she moved to
nutburger like as she was a sophomore
and she was dating a few guys as
and things happen like I was friends
with I know she did
like me like she just didn't like me for
some reason I didn't think the world are
either and one 984 I'm at a bar and this
comes in
I mean bangin bangin bangin
they also said she had some type of VD
so they called the Laurie jacked you
know he's got the jack now when they CDC
sang a song
he's got the jack Jack Jack's I used to
call her name and Jack like that was
right they just tormented this girl oh
then she date like a rocky like a rock
guilin had like long hair rocker and one
that I saw rocky and she was banging Joe
Rogan I am banging and I go you live in
North Bergen I shake yeah I didn't go to
college I I'm a bum a nanny I'm a nanny
and she told me the guys name and I knew
that guy that guy had a massage parlor
years earlier the guy that she was being
a nanny for now if she's his nanny he's
just that something's gotta be
wrong she looks so good in that
miniskirt she disappeared like 1:30 and
finally only three I'm sitting and I'm
like what am I gonna do tonight and I
had like a bag of cocaine oh it I'm
gonna go get it
so there's not crazy hours I went to the
dudes house where she's told me I'm out
the door was 3:15 in the morning and
he's out
Coco what are you doing hey girl I gotta
talk to Laurie there's something missing
he goes hold on
Laurie and she came down and she comes
outside he's got a robe on she's got a
robot and I looked at straight in the
face I don't listen I got like two eight
balls in my pocket get dressed let's get
the out of here and she said I
can't I go you have to and we will
argued there for like ten minutes I'm
like I wanna suck your I do dirty
things I don't give a about the VD
or the jack or the dry hump I'm on fire
and she said we'll give me ten minutes
nah I know how am I gonna sneak out I
don't know so I waited outside first
she's like I'll put Lou in bed now run
up about 15 minutes later I see her
running out with her purse with like a
bank deposit bag she's like him I
can't take it anymore
him we want foot it's 4:00 in the
morning there's a bunch of those dirty
hotels
saw my car I got a score I got coke
she's got
I'm gonna I'm excited we go back
to a hotel
we finally registers like $30 they asked
us through one of the jacuzzi in the
room and was one of those dirty
hotels on Tunnel II as you going in New
York City we went in there we walked in
and she was rule number one you are not
gonna find me it's 5:00 in the morning
there goes my there goes this
night and all she looks at me she goes
well if you could guess the color of my
panties I'll you I'm like okay red
and she goes there green but good enough
we started snorting cold
eat Mass I mean it was filthy and Doug
Flutie was throwing that quarterback
that cuts down the 1984 83 Doug Flutie's
I was waking up she was naked ripped
apart
I'm waking up and Doug Flutie strong the
touchdown I got dressed and got the
out and never saw her again
they robbed the money I took everything
she pops up on Facebook and I will hit
her back ago what color your panties
that's supposed to mean Oh Sherman arias
I know she gave yourself she had
something but I didn't give a
it was 84 Rock Hudson was dying I didn't
miss a condom I knew the consequences
I'm like it so I knew I was gonna
get something and I probably did I got
crabs after that over the holidays
before I got crabs
yeah 84 85 season I got crabs I found
that in the bathroom and Port Authority
I went to Port Authority and take a
and I pulled my pants down and I'm
sitting there reading the paper and I
see a crab like I saw something jump and
I'm like what the and I'd never
heard it I've never heard it nothing I
went home and took my underwear off got
like a magnifying glass it was over it
was all over they were all over the
couch I had to bring a bomb into the
room like one of those
wow it's really I grabbed it was crapped
up
oh my god lady next door knocked that
mic that I was living in Tenafly New
Jersey laying next door not so you have
a bug problem I'm like no help it wasn't
she moved in here there's been crabs in
[Applause]
[Music]